Las redes neuronales son una poderosa clase de algoritmos de aprendizaje automático
y vienen en muchas variedades
no es posible dedicarles la atención debida a las redes neuronales
en un video introductorio
como este; aquí solo identificaremos algunos componentes clave
de una red neuronal y el flujo de trabajo general
para que podamos entender cómo puede contribuir la computación cuántica
la red neuronal es un grafo conectado de neuronas
una neurona es básicamente solo algo que almacena un número
y ese número se llama frecuentemente activación: qué tan
encendida o apagada está la neurona
las neuronas están ordenadas en capas
y la primera capa es la capa de entrada
y la última es la capa de salida
entre ellas hay capas de procesamiento llamadas
capas ocultas; la activación de la
capa de entrada se carga directamente desde los datos a analizar
como el sombreado de píxeles en una imagen
las activaciones de la siguiente capa oculta están determinadas
por las neuronas de la capa de entrada
y por los pesos simbolizados por las líneas que conectan todas las neuronas
de la capa de entrada con todas las neuronas de la
siguiente capa; en otras palabras, determinamos la activación
de una neurona en la capa oculta
mediante una suma ponderada de todas las
activaciones de entrada; también podemos
aplicar un sesgo, un desplazamiento
podríamos querer activar una neurona
en la capa oculta no solo si la suma ponderada es
positiva, sino únicamente si supera un umbral grande
luego solemos aplicar una función compleja para obtener una activación
entre cero y uno, como una tangente hiperbólica
o a veces, de forma diferente, una
unidad lineal rectificada; no necesitas preocuparte
demasiado por estas por ahora; lo único
importante de estas funciones
es que son no lineales
de modo que la red en su conjunto contiene componentes tanto lineales
como no lineales
la misma suma ponderada de activaciones, esta vez
comenzando con las activaciones de la
primera capa oculta y los nuevos pesos
se extiende hasta la siguiente capa oculta
esto continúa hasta la capa final, que es la salida
la capa de salida tiene neuronas correspondientes a
categorías, y las activaciones nos indican
qué tan segura está la red de la clasificación
así que las categorías de salida en un análisis de imágenes podrían ser
perro, gato, hámster, etcétera
y una activación de 0,95 en la
neurona de perro indicaría un alto grado de certeza de que
la imagen es un perro; puedes iniciar tu red neuronal
con un conjunto aleatorio de pesos
y sesgos, o desde una configuración inicial razonablemente conocida
pero luego la idea es comprobar
qué tan bien clasifica las cosas tu red neuronal
y mejorarla; usamos una función de costo para describir
en qué medida se desvía nuestra red neuronal de la
clasificación correcta; esto implica calcular la
diferencia entre el valor real de una imagen
por ejemplo, un valor de uno en la neurona
de perro y cero en todas las demás neuronas de salida
y los valores predichos
sumamos sobre todas las categorías
de modo que no solo rastreamos si la categoría correcta fue
la más activada, sino que también podemos
rastrear si las activaciones incorrectas se reducen
sumamos sobre todos los ejemplos de nuestro conjunto de entrenamiento
y obtenemos un costo; luego
variamos los parámetros como los pesos en cada capa
entre todas las neuronas y los sesgos de cada una
se usan rutinas de optimización clásicas
para buscar un mínimo local en la función de costo
si no se hace nada para reducir la complejidad de esto
te puedes imaginar qué
espacio de parámetros tan astronómico hemos creado aquí
considera una red neuronal diseñada para analizar imágenes con
solo mil píxeles; esta red neuronal podría tener mil
neuronas de entrada, una sola capa oculta
y una salida binaria como gato o perro
este es el caso más simple de todos
y aun así corresponde a mil por mil
o un millón de pesos entre las capas de entrada y oculta
y otros dos mil entre las capas
oculta y de salida
posiblemente también unos mil o
más sesgos; así que esta red neuronal simple correspondería
a más de un millón de parámetros; aunque hay que ser justos:
los algoritmos modernos suelen hacer simplificaciones
en las redes neuronales clásicas
y hay campos enteros dedicados a hacer posible esta minimización
y hasta eficiente
pero el hecho es que este es un problema de
muy alta dimensionalidad
y entrenar una red neuronal
puede llevar mucho tiempo
y ser costoso; una red neuronal cuántica, o QNN,
funciona cargando primero los datos de entrada
y luego aplicando quantum circuits
correspondientes a los pesos entre capas
y finalmente una capa de medición
algunos puntos clave sobre esto: los datos
de carga y las ponderaciones son operaciones lineales
pero las mediciones son no lineales
así que, al igual que en las redes neuronales clásicas, tenemos
componentes tanto lineales como no lineales
además, los weight circuits
siguen teniendo parámetros variacionales
por lo que aún hay una minimización clásica por realizar
por supuesto, esto solo ha rozado la superficie de las redes neuronales cuánticas
pero esperamos que sigas aprendiendo sobre las aplicaciones
de las redes neuronales cuánticas
y otras aplicaciones de aprendizaje automático cuántico
con IBM Quantum